luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start welcome back to my show as always
it is powered by icon plus capital so quick news
announcement for you before we jump in because
today's one is different i feel like they're all
different so this is going to be fun so icons d
by balance dao launched last month with over 180
million dollars in total locked in value um more
d5 products are coming in may fiat on and off
ramps bridge and open money market on finance so
some always always more updates coming from icon
there now this is sponsored by blockbuy so gonna
give them a quick shout out you can get up to 250
when you sign up um which is pretty cool and
you can get up to 8.6 interest on your usdc
that's also pretty great given everything's
kind of like negative interest at the moment
particularly across europe so that's really good
news there um this is also live on youtube so if
you're watching on youtube make sure you hit the
follow turn hit the subscribe button hit the like
button so you never miss um any of my guests so
today's guest is marin altman the beautiful woman
using the stars to trade the crypto markets this
is pretty insane marin how are you i'm doing very
well how are you doing today i'm good i'm good
so where are you at the moment it looks stunning
i'm on my hotel balcony in dubai and if everything
could be shown i am right in front of the marina
the sun is setting it's beautiful so here visiting
probably for the final time before it gets too hot
before i apply for a residence so quick quick trip
here that's amazing where are you from initially
i am from new york born and raised in texas but
live in new york and um that's where i might be
splitting my time up with here in dubai in the
future just kind of avoiding those those covered
restrictions texas dubai i love it i love it
yeah but i've seen a lot of your work um it kind
of popped up in the end of 2020 the beginning
of 2021 um so i have so many questions for you
because it's so different from anything that i've
seen before you know people are always looking
at the fundamentals people are always looking at
technical analysis and obviously i'm sure you take
those things into account as well but you look at
astrology so you could really explain it better
than i can can you ex how would you define what
you do yeah i look at planetary cycles and the
positions of planetary bodies at certain moments
in correlation with events on earth or cycles of
events in history on earth so some astrologers
use that in a more psychological context to look
at how certain patterns correlate with certain
psychological or life events for individuals
in my adolescence i began to realize
that i had a passion for astrology in
a more worldly context and then as i entered
my 20s found finance i found that the specific
worldly context i liked to look at those
correlations within were financial markets
okay so break all of that down because i have to
be honest i really don't understand like i just
don't maybe it's because i'm not as um i don't
know the word i don't use creative but because
it's not the word but i just don't understand like
i see your videos and i don't get it so it's the
astrology part go on how you explain yeah so at
any given moment the planets are all positioned in
different ways around the earth in certain angles
and certain combinations and planets themselves
represent certain things and we have discovered
that through millennia of writing it down when
certain alignments and then certain events happen
so there's a lot of built up data to have theses
around this planet and aspect to this planet
indicates this kind of an event so with that we
can look at the moment that someone or something
was born whether that's a person or whether that
is a company or that is a token and see how the
current sky is in alignment with it um kind of
like you might think of weather forecasting but
then how that applies to the geography of a given
place so that if you're looking that there's if if
you see there's going to be rain coming somewhere
you'll still take that in context with what
the initial climate is whether it's rains a lot
whether rain is not very common to put
together what's happening versus the context
for where it's happening and then form um form an
inference so i'm seeing alignments that represent
mostly either favorable or unfavorable alignments
um favorable being indicative of a price increase
or good news for like a project or a token and
then unfavorable being something detrimental or
something that looks more like you know a bearish
indicator for the market so it's very very similar
to technical analysis where we're using patterns
to predict the future because it's all cyclical
um it just happens that the chart is circular
and not candlestick so yeah so can you give me
an example of what would be a good thing and what
would be a bad thing i know that could be quite
broad but just so i can really wrap my head around
what you look for sure so the favorable planets
are generally jupiter and venus they indicate i
just like to say cute [ __ ] generally jupiter
yeah so yeah so in middle of may around may
16th jupiter in the sky will be crossing over
the location that venus was at when bitcoin's
genesis block was released so okay jupiter's
crossing the exact location of where venus is
in bitcoin's chart so like jupiter plus venus
double cute [ __ ] essentially so trying to
simplify it down that way astrology is a hell
of a lot of math that i don't do myself i get
calculations to do and then i just see it and i'm
like okay jupiter crossing venus that's favorable
something happening around the same time is that
um the two planets that indicate unfavorable
things or bearishness are mars and saturn
and um mars will be opposing pluto where it was in
bitcoin's chart at its time of the genesis block
which is mars in a direct opposition to another
planet pluto which can be more unfavorable
looks more bearish so we're seeing kind of
um a game of combination and then what is
the last results because often there's
going to be multiple things going on
and you have to see which are more powerful or
what you're outweighing the the other side so
it might sound ridiculous um because obviously you
do this so you obviously nothing sounds ridiculous
okay good that's scary okay so how effective is
it so like how much um what kind of results have
you had by following this um system when it comes
to trading and because you trade right yeah i do
i do i'm definitely in profit because of this um
preemptively i i am more geared towards i mean me
myself being a more like skeptical or critical
person i can spot unfavorables and like oh that
looks bad like it's going to go down so i'm going
to be like i want to have usdt on hand to buy in
and then there's a really striking correlation
with full moons being local bottoms and new
moons being local tops there was a chart right
recently full moons hormones being local bottoms
of it yeah whether it's an uptrend or a downtrend
like just local bottoms as it ebbs and flows
and new moons being local tops so for example if i
am um more short-term trading all coins like swing
trading i will try to buy in around the full moon
for things that i think have a fundamental and a
technical narrative to back it so like i use all
three where every time it's around a full moon
i'm thinking what positions do i want to add to
what narratives are bringing the space right now
i'm really bullish on exchange tokens and um also
like nft projects so i'll add positions to those
around the new moon i'll then look and see what
looks like there might be bullish divergence
a narrative dying out to where i think it
looks a bit overvalued and i'll take profit
so i use it and i'm in profit i am not perfect
there are times when i am like that was there
are times where i look back i'm like oh my god
that was a [ __ ] like why didn't you see that
so i'm definitely not uh infallible like i it's
human error but it is really key for narrowing
down and not being overwhelmed with the ta
or fundamental analysis that can seem like
there are so many different options of where
to go i can narrow it down with astrology yeah
and astrology is one of those things um like
so many things in life whether it's like um
uh bear with me you know like hypnosis or um or
alternative medicine you know all these sorts
of alternative things which people laugh at um
and they don't believe in right so yes and now
now you're bringing this into something which is
let's just call it a man's world because because
it is and this is something that like yeah men
totally you know oppose like women are more
interested in astrology women are more interested
in alternative medicine women are more interested
in in all the like fluffy stuff let's just call it
so so what kind of backlash have you had because
you know you're really putting this in like
you're bringing astrology into maths and and
science and stuff like that yeah so really yeah
this came really organically in the way that like
2020 started i was like i'm graduating from
university i don't know jack [ __ ] about finance
i am practical but i wasn't taught anything i'm
a philosophy student like i didn't know anything
about anything i had a debit card january 2020 i i
open up rich dad poor dad i'm like no wonder in my
own astrology there's a huge emphasis on finance
that i refuse to acknowledge for all of my life
because i was like i'm going to be an actor like
why is there money like what what interest do you
have in being an accountant um now i see no it's
because you're interested in finance itself but
um i started getting really into investing and
diving into crypto at the march 2020 crash and
it just became like my obsession literally i was
like this is when history is made um so you better
like really ape into this and it was such
an honest interest in crypto and then using
astrology because that's what i know how
to use to chart trends that as it emerged
and i started posting about it on tik tok as
i was growing for political videos as well
i didn't even think about like i didn't i didn't
know that there were like astrologers that were
already doing this that were doing crypto and
astrology now i'm aware of like there are a
number of financial structures who do do crypto
but i was just kind of like this is fun for me
and then during the fall um accounts like tick
tock investors and some other ones started
posting them and i'm a pretty i like to say like
i just don't take too much overly seriously like
i don't know like the mimification of me like
calling me thinking i'm crazy i'm like bring it
i don't really care so i'd say the backlash
i find it mostly even if they might mean it
maliciously i don't i don't know i don't take
it maliciously um i think it's funny i'm like
i'm shattering their worldview and that's
fine this is welcome uh so it definitely had
a lot of backlash either uh
favorably or unfavorably i guess
like there's been some weird ones like
ben shapiro retweeted me and that was
it was a video about the election that involved
financial markets really going through trouble in
early 2021 and um it was just a weird thing where
she he was like this is better than like what did
he say the like some he mentioned some financial
uh analyst group and then and 538 yeah and it was
a weird moment because i remember i'm just eating
breakfast at the same table that i've been at my
entire you know 20 early 20s um and now this is
happening so i'd say the backlash is mostly shock
oriented even if they might need a malicious sleep
i don't take that much seriously and i'm like it's
all in good fun so feel free keep my name in
your mouth like go for it i'm cool for chillin
so yeah yeah i think that's such a great mentality
um i think the thing with this space is that um
everybody is very set in their ways and it's i've
noticed that people don't necessarily like mass
adoption um because it kind of feels like it's and
it's a club and it's something that we have and
you know i guess and i can understand that and i
really can because like having been in this space
for a few years now i do sort of feel like you
know when i've been telling my friends by bitcoin
and then they don't and then now everybody's
asking i'm sort of just like go away you know so
i can understand um but you said that you studied
philosophy and you only recently got into finance
that's amazing so i want to hear more about that
so the crash in march 2020 that's what it was how
did you learn about crypto then because that was
literally a year ago yeah so january 2020 is when
i was like yeah you don't know anything like
literally you have a debit card and you don't
you don't even like i'm i wasn't bad with money
necessarily i'm a responsible person it's just
not something they teach you and i was very heavy
into like not even in philosophy i was not into
philosophy of science or logic i openly nearly
failed logic because it was so difficult for me
to quantify basic things like the coding classes
i took which were very basic were something that i
could tell was basically was just not the way that
i think um and so i geared more towards ethics and
metaphysics and like philosophy of language and
things like that um and once i started preparing
to graduate um kovitz started kind of creeping in
and i realized like i just had a lot more time on
my hands to not have to commute to class every
day like in new york and that led to one joining
tick-tock and two being able to read more like for
pleasure and i really like non-fiction so i bought
rich dad poor dad i bought the little common sense
book of investing which both of them convinced me
by assets not liabilities good tip um and
then the little common sense book of investing
taught me to buy low-cost index funds and i
thought i had solved the world i was like i'm
gonna buy low-cost index funds i'm gonna beat the
market told all my friends i'm like buy low-cost
index funds lo and behold i open an ira and uh
accidentally put the entire year maximum into
tesla which worked out very well but was not as i
intended i meant to buy an index fund messed it up
that was actually the catalyst for how can
this be so difficult for me to buy something
be delayed it'd be difficult for me to set up
these accounts accidentally make six iras barely
qualify basically for these bank accounts because
i don't know i'm like not i was just graduating
university i was like why is it so difficult
for me to just open a [ __ ] bank account like
this is ethically ridiculous like the middlemen
component of this is just insane i i don't know
if something's inefficient and intolerable like
i don't i don't stand by i'm going to be like why
that philosophical background of like
interrogating things and finding a
uh like i'm utilitarian i like to maximize
efficiency and pleasure and minimize harm
and ridiculousness and so when things are out
of balance with that my mind is like when is
the equation wrong and the financial system it
was like business this is absurd and from there
i found crypto pretty easily because philosophy
student plus interest in finance was like bitcoin
likes kind of entry level uh libertarian financial
kind of meetings was pretty pretty immediate i did
not buy into crypto immediately because i was
so interested in learning more about it i then
bought into it later in the summer and all i did
that entire year because i don't spend that much
or need that much to live on was put everything
i could into bitcoin everything everything and
uh from that that then allowed me to have a
good time i just closed yeah yeah yeah um and
from there it gave me like i like to consider
money just a form of pure energy of transaction
and the way that we exchange exchange energy and
building that up throughout the year allowed me
to then have more more of a canvas to play with
ethereum and altcoins and things like that so um
my crypto journey came from being like i need to
grow up i should learn about finance uh this is
highly ridiculous and crypto seems to be the next
logical step in addressing that ridiculousness
and i think what's interesting is you said that it
was kind of the mixture of philosophy and bitcoin
which kind of made sense so okay so what kind
of philosophy because for me i might i was in
politics first like i'm in love with politics i'm
a libertarian um and so that's why the connection
was just like duh obviously so when you say
philosophy do you mean political philosophy or
do you mean i i guess philosophy kind of extends
to that um but what kind of philosophy really
yeah the philosophy that i specialized in war
looked like i was really big into ethics and in
particular i got really deep into utilitarianism
because i have a pretty myopic mind and so i like
weighing out the utility to the point of driving
myself crazy of like what is the simplest path to
this what will maximize return to the point where
sometimes i'm so focused on maximizing return
i get no return which happens in my financial
decisions as well i can be doing so much research
on all coins and what kind of allocation i want
in a company to where the opportunity passes and
it's already gone up or something so there's
pluses and minuses to being an over analyst but
the philosophy that i think led me into
yeah similarly libertarian leanings was
looking into actually i did a class on political
philosophy and ethics and we read a lot of john
stewart mill um like on liberty and reading that
and there were some points that i highly agreed
with which was kind of the um ways that society
molds things into usually a healthier ecosystem
but can remove the innovation that comes with
non-conformism um and things like that where i
just started to think on a larger worldview of the
systems that we were creating and how some of them
are just cultural inertia rather than linear
progress i'm really into i mean i guess like
every early 20s girl i'm really into nietzsche and
on the genealogy of morals i that really spoke to
me early in my college career because it um very
clearly laid out how we are not on a linear path
to improvement maybe we are like the market kind
of eventually going up but there's a lot of ups
and downs in different areas of the world and i
felt like the financial system was a great example
of going very very far in a certain direction with
trying to help out by interfering a lot in the
world when perhaps the best solution is occam's
razor and like get everything out and let the
free market world kind of correct itself and
seeing 2020 be the opposite of that where our
stock market is on stilts um i think that there's
so much artificiality that it brings in ethical
considerations so my philosophy of wanting the
simplest path because that brings in the least
i guess uh casualties that are just extraneous in
the world and the utilitarian path of just like
just just cut to the just the simplest thing which
does not seem to be this extreme manipulation
um led me very very quickly into crypto and
i think that energetic alignment is why i've
been extremely lucky with the people and the
opportunities that i've been able to meet up with
in this space and you mentioned john you mentioned
john stuart mill so i did a class on ethics um
when i was at university and um philosophy and all
that stuff and he's the guy that speaks about um
freedom of speech right he's the one that says
if um if we all just tell the truth eventually
sorry if we allow freedom of speech the
truth will eventually rise to the top
so that's like something which really
kind of shaped my political leanings
and therefore bitcoin and everything like
that like i think what's really interesting
is all the tribalism in the
space um i think i just saw today
um that um i can't remember how to
pronounce his last name but chama
so he's a bitcoin og like he bought bitcoin
right in his words when everyone else was still
still in their mom's basement right right
um but he dabbles in other things and is
interested in other coins supposedly [ __
] coins so he's been de-platformed which
i thought was really interesting um because
john stuart mills is the guy that i kind of
really connected with when he said yeah freedom of
speech and then the truth will rise to the top um
i wonder if you had any thoughts on any of the
tribalism yeah well for one that's kind of sad
because i can definitely disagree with chemoth on
some things mostly because i come from a point of
for better for worse a beginner's mind in the
grand scheme of things where i might have less
tainting but also a bit of naivete so like some
of the things he says i'm like but then i don't
know but i i appreciate jamal for the most part
um so i'm sad to see that he will not be at the
conference that i actually will be going to the
lectures for because i'm a nerd like i actually
want to see these things so i was excited to see
him but alas i think that the tribalism and i've
seen other people speak about this is because of
the ethical or the philosophical conviction that
nearly everyone gets into the space with whether
that is a conviction that we should accumulate
profit because that you know is something that
has been taken away from a lot of people that
might not have access to generational wealth
which i think is an ethical motive you know i
don't see profit or money as bad or negative it's
simply energy and i think there's some people who
more like me it was the efficiency or the
wrongdoing of the gatekeeping and the euphemisms
that make finance seem like this old guys club and
it's really just the discussion of energy and you
can put whatever [ __ ] word you want on it but
it's not that difficult like it's not as difficult
as these words make it seem um yes that got me
into the space with an awareness of kind of the um
the emotions that come in with it and i think that
it's a lot of people's replacement for myth or for
story or narrative in their life to feel like
they're working directly with a medium of value
and that their path to working with that value is
justified and i remember i don't think i realized
the gravity of what i was saying because
i can agree wholeheartedly that bitcoin is
the best store of value as a digital gold out
of any coin philosophically completely agree i
think it will get to a point where we all want
to be holding a certain amount of bitcoin for
you know like this is my safety net i used to
call myself a reformed bitcoin maxi because i
like to leverage all coins that will return much
higher to then have a bigger safety net of bitcoin
that does not fly because i'm not hodling and
i'm not i don't know like sleeping with a ledger
under my pillow of just like the bitcoin that i
bought in like 1995 2012 13. i don't know but like
um i think that part of the tribalism is a
you know replacement for a myth or religion or
community in a space that often comes out of
feeling like you take issue with the communities
that people are ascribing to whether that is
left right like members of this whatever in the
world it's a lot of um factions that arise out of
meaning well and i think that if you were like i
used to say ironically a big a reformed bitcoin
maxi i didn't fully mean that you know i i don't
have huddle in my name um and my twitter handle
but i think that anyone who wholeheartedly is a
maximalist i think it's a little narrow-minded
because there's always a caveat and um i
think it is in good fun i i you know i invite all
the different factions and groups and i don't take
it too seriously i'm just kind of like you know
my i guess my fact is just like maximizing the
simplest path to making the best of the space um
and like i'm leverage different coins for that
yeah i think you have the correct mindset
you can't take any of this too seriously
you absolutely cannot um if you take it too
seriously you're just going to be miserable um
and i'm totally with you like i i also agree i
think bitcoin is digital gold it's the best store
of value we've ever seen like michael saylor
says it's you know the best savings technology
there is it's my safety net it's the love of my
life it's the thing which is basically you know
gonna be there if all else fails um but
you know if you can make some quick gains
i don't see why not you know you can trade
some old coins to buy more bitcoin i don't
get why it's that deep and why it's that
emotional but i definitely agree with you um
when you say you know yeah it's not but i
definitely agree with you when you say that um
you know people need that kind of like community
and i do think that that's where where it comes
from because we see tribalism you know across
the board whether it's in whether it's religion
um gender um oh have i still got you yeah you're
going to like the shutter yeah mine does that as
well i'm good yeah i'm going to you can keep
going i'm here i'm going to delete the um the
video that is taking up space because now that i'm
in dubai i uh don't have oh go for it no worries
so yeah so whether it whether it's you know
tribalism in um in sports whether it's tribalism
you know with gender politics whatever it
is i feel like people always need people
always need some form of community to belong
to and i do think that's what it comes down to
um but you made a video which i thought was
really cool it totally blew up so congrats
um the video was about bitcoin scarcity and how um
okay how do i put this because i want to try try
try articulate this basically you you're looking
at yourself as a woman going through her 20s and
you were saying as i get older i have less time
left that makes me more valuable that makes my
time more valuable just like bitcoin i thought
that was really cool so can you tell me more
about this how did you um come to that train of
thought yeah in the way that i conceptualize a
lot of the reasons why i'm interested in crypto
it generally does go back to like philosophy and
even if i'm quote in it for the tech it's
because like it's tech that i think is going
to philosophically change the world um yeah
and so with that when i think of bitcoin it
was just really life-changing to be like you can
hold something for money that is of value um and
isn't just like discovering the difference
between the frivolousness or meaninglessness
of fiat currency versus something that is even
it's though it's intangible it's meaningful um
spoke to me and with bitcoin increasing in value
the less that it is available i started thinking
of like how a lot of my worries for the future
come with a lot of my career was leveraged on sure
providing like valuable insightful things but
no one no one would have spotted me in the first
place if i wasn't you know black and red haired
looked the way i did the kinds of things that come
with the awareness of being like a young woman
and knowing that biologically like i'm in like
the peak of being able to use this and i'm not
afraid to speak about it or be like that's kind
of a weird concept to think of like looking back
i mean like that was the height of when i was most
captivating physically online what would be a way
of knowing that i would be worth taking up space
and value when it's not the immediate you know
gut impulse to watch them because of what they
look like and if bitcoin gets more valuable the
less that it exists in the world because what
remains is valuable so therefore less of it
is exponentially more valuable then why isn't
me who i would consider valuable in what i provide
also being thought of as more valuable the less of
me that remains and i don't think that's morbid um
i feel really comfortable discussing death and i
guess the fear or acknowledgement of the downside
of aging and i really find especially women who
just like hold their openness with aging like i
i like to see like almost like beautiful aging
on people because i i think it speaks to this um
but if bitcoin can be valuable as there's less of
it remaining then maybe it's not so bad for me to
get old and wrinkly and uh just be a brain and not
so much a body anymore maybe it means it's more
valuable in the long run yeah i i totally um i i
totally understood your train of thought when you
posted that and i was like that's that's really
funny that um like somebody i've never spoken
to is is kind of like thinking like that and
i totally understood it um what was the kind of
reaction you had because i know obviously it was
it blew up but like what kind of response did
you get funny enough i posted it on tick tock and
didn't blow up at all um i yeah because on tick
tock what blows up is the very like click bait
15 second joke videos and there are times when
authentically i'm in a good mood i want to post
that and they're also most of the time when i
know that i don't consume any content like that
i consume very little tick tock maybe one to two
videos when i open the app to post but i don't sit
there scrolling and when i do look at something
it's usually a one minute crypto or philosophy or
personal finance or real estate related video so
i don't sit there and watch any of the trends so
when that video didn't really blow up
in tiktok i wasn't surprised because
um definitely now thinking in terms of value
not just views when i posted it on twitter
and it started to blow up and i gained some
followers that i really respect in the space
like some thinkers i know found me through
that it was kind of interesting to see that
people could resonate because i even though i have
had quite a few incredible viral opportunities
that is just the surface of the amount of like
hundreds of thousands of pieces of content that
don't get seen that are more valuable than that
that usually gets seen so sure there were some
weird things where people didn't bother to
watch the video and most of the it doesn't
bother me when people leave quote physical hate
like i couldn't care less i grew up acting this
is a biological space suit i don't care say what
you want to try to make a funny point some people
were like this is a top signal and like that was
old in october 2020 like i [ __ ] been here like
thank you no someone else thought of that joke
um and then some of them were just kind of like
this is weird that bitcoin maxies think this
and i'm like the bitcoin maxies don't blame me
yeah yeah so most every single criticism was a
misunderstanding or a projection of trying to
make a joke and be witty exactly exactly whereas
90 of it was like wow and i'm like oh like people
appreciate it like i to this day anytime i get
it's inhuman to be able to consider the amount
of people that might appreciate what i'm doing so
anytime i can see and connect with that it's like
oh thank you even if i like like every single
time like when people see me and i'm checking
my comments i'm like oh like i'm visually
like in like reacting so it was that's why i
pinned it and i don't usually have a pin tweet
because i'm like there's there's no point um
because of how fast the space moves but that spoke
to me and i did it i did it in dubai a month ago
in the same hotel like two it was this floor like
two um balconies down at night no makeup the night
before my flight at like 2 a.m just filmed
it like it worked yeah yeah i think you know
that's the best kind of content where it just
comes from the heart it's totally random yeah
um and yeah it just comes from the heart and
i i i totally get it i think it was i think it
was really really interesting thank you um so in
terms of your personal life and your career goals
where do you see yourself i know you said you're
obviously moving to dubai um but outside of that
like woody where do you see yourself what
are you doing for work what are the goals
yeah so yeah the current priority is uh
because of where i see the world heading
and there's actually a good quote i believe it's
jim rogers who said something along the lines of
1800 you moved to london 1900 you moved to new
york 2000's you moved to asia and the same energy
that had me moved to new york from texas because
i felt like that go-getter energy of wanting to
change the world is the same exact energy that
can see that i want to keep a place in new york
i don't want to depend or live there full-time
and places in asia like dubai or singapore
where the priority is on maximizing freedoms and
using the government in a way that keeps sanity
instead of impedes on businesses especially
because there's not a demonization of success
or wealth because it's understood that that is
simply a lot of energy and that can be either
required poorly or really authentically um i
can see where that's heading and so i'm thinking
firstly that a career goal is to for one set up
you know businesses and things outside of the
country um as i you know prepare to be more um
be more in like the asian i see this kind of an
emerging intellectual market for this kind of uh
liberty based work i want to create things that
are not fighting against where history is heading
and i think history is heading towards a.i
and decentralization and i love astrology and
i know that i am passionate about research and
what i've done so far however i think that the
future will be ai and that actually scared me
a few years ago there were pieces i made where i
thought it was like ethically wrong and now i've
really completely gone around the corner where i'm
like if it scares me because it's new then i want
to join forces with it there's several projects
that i'm heavily invested in because i'm like
that's going to scare people and piss people off
like i want to be on the front lines for that
and can you tell me more about that what kind
of like what kind of ai scared you and that
yeah i had a change of heart on i i think that
i was honestly um surrounded by in a mind space
of really wanting like humanness to not go out
of style or be valued for simply being human like
me value us and now i see it as the benefit
to humanity can come when more and more is
automated and less and less can be done by
humans that what is done by humans is more
valuable because the value of our work or the the
amount of energy it takes to do our work will fill
to the amount of space that we are provided
so if we live in a huge house and we're alone
that might be more detrimental to your day-to-day
routine than living in a adequately but more
concise space if you give yourself three weeks
to write a one-page paper it's probably going to
be extremely taxing as opposed to three hours to
write that paper um it's just gonna drag out so if
i if we can have less to fill as humans
that doesn't require um if we can outsource
extraneous monotonous tasks or tasks that can be
better done by automation it will allow us to be
forced to work within a system that maximizes our
potential and astrology one-on-one consultations
are beautiful and i think that scaling that
is not as sustainable as thinking i want to
build a platform that can provide astrological
delineations and things not just in a cookbook
style but like more intelligent where ai i'm not
um extremely literate on the science of ai but i
do understand that you know there's intelligence
to it it's not you know uh it's not a formula like
regular you know maybe yeah of course yeah so
i think that if we can outsource that and we
can continue trying to build to maximize ai
which is just smarter and is going to have
i get that in astrology there's a human compassion
component with the way that you present something
and also there's error in that you might get the
calculation wrong you might delineate it wrong
with ai i think that there's less room
for air and a lot of that so i would in
the future like to develop a system that
is decentralized so that it's not like
writers getting to put their favoritism or bias
into what the ai is saying but i i know co-stars
all is already doing this to an extent and i
did a video where i railed on co-star and like
if i ever meet these people like i want to i
didn't really blow up i was a nobody until six
months ago but i would honestly be like you know
i apologize i had a change of heart keep doing you
because it scares people and it pisses people off
but i can see behind that in the future it'll be
this is what's done to further businesses um and
i think decentralization is the future because
as as we have more space to make day-to-day
decisions the more complex decisions reveal
themselves as being silly so like the fact that
going towards bank you have intermediaries ach
i just had to do to get my polish passport that
i'm getting through dissent is like five days to
wire a couple hundred euros like i was literally
like can i just send you ethereum they're like
what is ethereum i'm like okay thank you um and i
think that decentralization is just a product of
efficiency and people with efficiency there comes
more time and space to think and people realize
when there's unnecessary steps so decentral
i think like d5 projects i want to build some
of my own and i'm very aware that it's very real
that there's a possibility of talented people who
use me as a public figure to not create the best
project have it maybe fall through and that's on
me so i'm extremely careful in not wanting to be
as naive as i am now before launching but i think
anything that liberates people from like i guess
allows them to be more sovereign with the way that
their manage their energy aka their money is so
necessary so i'm very focused on astrology within
ai and d5 in general in mostly like i don't know
there's a bunch of d5 projects that are like um
staking yield farming collateral is it
collateralization like cross chain like
whatever and i'm like i don't i don't i you lost
you lost me about the third term how can i just
help the average person in a way that leverages
the geniuses that are developers and also makes
the average person more stable because no one
should be living paycheck to paycheck um i think
equal opportunity is important it's what people
decide to do with that and defile out for that
yeah i think um so there's so much there
so i'll just click a pick up of your last
yeah so i i'm also with you like i'm not super
super techy i'm in a world where i'm trying to
essentially liaise that message from the geniuses
the techie people to the average person who just
wants to find value right um right so that's
very much my my goal as well and i think like
in terms of ethics i i look at the traditional
financial system and i just think it's so
it's not just trash but it's actually a scam that
is set out to hurt the little person and so i you
when i look at these different d5 projects and
like you know the different kind of interests
that people can make and yield farming and all
this stuff and i'm just like wow you know like
this could be really interesting um right you said
you said something earlier and i can't remember
what it was but i really wanted to pick you pick
you up on it um oh ai okay so on the ai point
i'm with you i definitely understand the whole
outsourcing and you know it can it means that
we can make our time more valuable and purposeful
you know we understand that in business anyway um
but but but i have this thing where i feel i'm
concerned that if we really remove the human
from the human experience it's going to make
things dark and dull for example um so i went
out for lunch back in summer in england when um
it was open but because of covin they weren't
serving you directly and i think i went into this
restaurant i ate a full meal and i didn't speak
to one person that worked there the entire time
no waiter no like and it just wasn't nice and i
didn't like it and then i thought to myself okay
well this is this is where we're going with a.i
um and i didn't like it i much more prefer
to have the human involved what do you think
i think that's definitely you could argue a bug
or a feature depending on your preference in
the context because i agree that now some of the
things that seem like they will be here to stay
um similar to how 911 enforce new restrictions
for travel and uh gathering this has introduced
things like especially in dubai where it's um the
cutting edge of a lot of the ways in which this
was dealt with and it got a handle on things
very quickly like there's very rarely menus
it's all qr codes and something about that like i
like i'm like i'm like a paper person like i like
to grab i i don't know if this is like i smell
my books and i like menus and tangible things
heavy earth sign energy in my chart i like to be
grounded and like feel things and that feeling and
also um the rise of just i don't even know like
calling or dealing with a problem online with
customer service and being completely automated
and then sometimes they're not understanding you
does worry me in some ways that when there's an
issue sometimes the creativity and the softness
of humans can fill in gaps and misplaced
parties where if it's a system and there's
a part that doesn't fit you're just going to be
kept out so that if there's a mishap it's more
likely to be more noticeable so i think it's a
case-by-case thing but there are some things where
my motto throughout this has been like if i'm
really bullish on ai it makes me motivated to
live a life that ai cannot replicate and most
things it can and then one that it may be like
when i think of anything whether it's being like
witty or provocative or saying things that um seem
cutting edge i think in a i might do that better
because i might not have the emotional setback
of like that's going to piss people off it might
have a faster reaction time to doing you know more
productive statement or with or whatever um so
it's a case-by-case thing of trying to maximize my
crew of creativity and my individuality and um not
having an answer to whether it's right or whether
it is better and personal preference in some
ways because some things i don't want to deal
with the human about and some things and like
i miss menus and waiters and things like that
yeah i miss menus i'm totally with you um yeah but
i wonder do you have an opinion on elon musk's um
simulation theory then given your interest
in ai do you think we're in a simulation
kind of like the idea of free will you can make
the idea of a simulation into whatever fits
your comfort zone with the kind of reality
we're in so if you literally think that we
are in the one-to-one equivalent of a computer
game with another species watching or playing
i don't think that i think that you could argue
that this is a playing ground for a larger
architecture of the universe i think that
astrology and the way that there's correlations
that repeat over time hints at a larger
intelligence than just humans and that's not
woo it's similar to how aliens are likely and
we still have little proof it's likely just
given the way in which reality is structured
but we have little causal proof of this and i
think that the simulation theory um if you want
to argue that we're in a simulation um i would
want you to explain the implications of what that
causally means like are we agents of our own will
are we playing for entertainment for someone um
because you could argue that life is a simulation
because we all have our own reality or
you could argue that it's a simulation
because like me you think more in terms of
there must be something greater than this
not in a magical way but just honestly what
i think is logical um but i'm not going to
think that the human intelligence is the extent
of the most intelligent thing in the universe
um so similar to like free will on like whether we
have it or not we're going to act the same but if
you think it's a simulation cool i can't disprove
it or prove it i'm not gigabrained enough for that
no i get you well i mean that's pretty gigabrain
uh pretty gigabrain response i give you that
my kind of take on the whole simulation thing
is so i look at things very uh in a very basic
straightforward way i just look at the facts
and see if i can what i can take yeah and
he says we're in a simulation right got it
okay i understand the three the three things
he says either either we did it and we got that
either something happened so catastrophic that
um we never were able to advance that far or we
decided it would be inhumane but my issue which
would really i'd love to interview him one day
my issue which i can't get my head around is but
i definitely think that we're gonna get that from
a tech standpoint but who says that somebody got
there before us like we we could just be like time
could just be this linear and we are the first
and then i don't know and then we eventually get
there it kind of that's my only issue with it
because i do definitely agree that you know things
have advanced so far yeah and so quickly um but
you mentioned free will so go on i gotta get your
thoughts on that do you think we have free will
i think that we have free choi so i think in
free will there's two different things that we
should consider that everyone is conditioned
and you could say that based on your nurture
you do not have absolute free will to do
everything outside of where you're conditioned
i don't think that conditioning counts as an
impediment to free will i think if everyone is
conditioned then let's just consider okay can you
make your own actions without being manipulated by
like an internal party i do think that we do have
free will because i don't think that conditioning
is an impediment on free will as much as a feature
of it because we live in a world where there's
factors and things intermingling you have free
will amongst those things to choose however i also
think that astrology and being able to predict
the future and see cycles repeat maybe even ta
which i call astrology ta for all of reality
cycles repeat and we can use that to discern
that there's a larger framework so i believe that
everything is completely and wholly determined
i think that if you're saying that there's some
things that are determined and some things that
aren't that you're just scared to say that it's
all determined because you think that that means
that you aren't making your own decisions i
would argue that we're completely making our
own decisions and that if we were omnisciently at
the end of the timeline we would be able to see
how we make all of those decisions so we are
both the agents of our own life and we are
playing a life that has been predetermined because
i think that the most logical conception of this
and this is really wacko and weird and i've
written a lot of papers on this i've gotten
a lot of mixed opinions whether it's like insane
or kind of makes sense is that we're experiencing
time linearly when it must be a completely larger
system that is so many dimensions and we have to
simplify it down into this follows this follows
this i don't believe in causality i believe in
like a chain of interactions and everything
is happening we're experiencing it linearly
so we both have the free will to create our own
lives but if we were not humans we were gods
being able to see the entire timeline we would
see everything we're about to do even if we're
the ones doing it so like you are writing your
own story and living out at the same time yeah
interesting interesting yeah no it's good it's
good um i i often wonder i i also agree i think
that we're we're living time linearly but i
don't think that that's how it actually is
i don't think it seems yeah that if we
were gods or on a higher level or whatever
we would be able to see i even have this idea
about reincarnation whereby say you have like
this bubble right so time isn't linear it's
just this bubble i think that you can exist
simultaneously in different in different eras
and times even while you're still alive yeah
i genuinely think that's possible because time
isn't linear so like if i let's say god forbid
i died tomorrow i could easily be brought
back three weeks in advance let's say a bait
i'm the new baby that's born at the same time
as me being alive because time's not linear so
i have this whole theory about reincarnation which
i definitely think is true like i definitely think
there is we are you could meet yourself because
time isn't linear does that make sense there's
some yeah there's some weird ways that that could
work um when i was in a couple metaphysics courses
at nyu i got really deep into time travel
because there's arguments about how long yeah
there's legitimate arguments for why or why not
it's logically possible and why or why not it's
physically possible like there are two different
arguments the physical possibility can almost be
explained easier than the logical one or i'm sorry
the logical one can almost be explained easier
but the physical one can be an issue because
like if you're meeting yourself then parents and
descendancy and things like that and like messing
up the timeline and how harry potter where harry
meets himself is a good example of something
that is not logically consistent basically um
if someone's to go with that they can look into
it where harry meets his himself across with his
patronus and like the sixth film i think um and
yeah i think that um there's a lot you can do with
time travel where it's not it's like a highly
discussed academic topic like it's not taboo
um and no i tend to think it will likely be
possible and that we could really mess up
we can mess up a lot if it goes wrong so it's
very exciting i'm excited to probably look down
maybe in my next life or a next planet and be like
huh earth earth [ __ ] everything up because they
time traveled back and messed up a berth yeah well
time travel forward is possible it's the time it's
time travel backwards because if you're like i'm
obsessed with with time travel right interstellar
is my favorite film so if you're moving um faster
than the speed of light or like if you're let's
say you remove yourself because obviously time
is not fixed it depends on like mass and gravity
so if you go to another planet with like a larger
mass then time will obviously move slower for you
so then if you then come back to earth everybody's
aged but you're still the same so time travel
forward we get but i have no idea how time travel
back would work i don't know if you know yeah
go on some of the yeah some of the time
travel back that would it would involve
having to go back to a specific event and then
some of there's some weird theories um like you
would kill yourself how do you get back but
how do you get back that's the thing is that
the physical the physical part is often
theorized where like it yeah where it's
not clear how you would physically do it but it
logically makes sense that's why like the logical
thing is like if yeah where physically you know
you can make something up and there's a lot of
issues of like double space where if you're time
traveling somewhere would you run into an object
there and then not exist so there's like issues
of like you want to make sure that your time
travel box is like in a field there's it's really
cool it's really cool there's some cool if anyone
wants those resources i can pull out my old
textbooks and like tell you the articles and
things but uh yeah yeah yeah no it's a great
topic it's been so brilliant chatting to you
um i feel like we have so much in common um i'd
love to come to dubai when you're settled i feel
like we really could we could talk for hours over
a drink and just like talk about absolute rubbish
i'm sure we could but where can people find
you what are you up to just plug yourself now
i am marin altman on all socials so that's
mostly tick tock twitter instagram and youtube
can't think of anything else i'm on so if
it if it's me like scamming or asking for
money it's not me people fall for this every
video they're like thank you for sharing this
telegram group where i'm like pay me and i'm like
that's not me um so watch out for scammers but
marin altman pretty simple all platforms and um
i recently started a second youtube channel so
you can find both of those in my links to separate
astrology and then astron crypto you can subscribe
to both if you still want to see everything in
your feed but i was getting some feedback of
like i don't really want this so i split it up
like three days ago so that's out but um marin
altman everywhere you can find me uh pretty simple
and yeah feel free to leave anything i get all
i like to see what people leave the good the bad
the ugly so chime in i love it marin thank you
so much it's been so brilliant and we definitely
need to meet somewhere in the world we'll do it
yes 100 would love to bring you on my show and
chat because i think we're yeah very very similar
yeah absolutely guys thank you so much for
watching i will see you all next week bye bye